Good man, good man, good man. So I see
that you have on the on the screen you
said the Bible is authority over the
Quran. Can I ask what you mean? I mean
that the Bible is the standard of truth
over the Quran. If the Quran is not in
line with the Bible, then the Quran is
false. If it's in line with the Bible,
then it's good to go.
>> what's your evidence? What's your
evidence for that? Chapter 10 verse 94.
And I treat it If you are in doubt, oh
Muhammad, that's in brackets by the way,
regarding that which we have sent down,
then go and ask those who have been
reading the scripture before you.
The truth has come to you from your
Lord, so be not of those who doubt.
Okay. So what's your argument here?
What's What are you trying to say?
What's your main point? So the argument
is this. Allah tells Muhammad that if he
is in doubt about the Quran, if he's
uncertain about the truth about the
Quran, Mhm.
>> then for him to get certainty regarding
the truth of the Quran, he can go ask
those who read the Bible, read the
scriptures before him. Meaning that
that's going to help him get certainty
about the Quran because the Quran will
be in line with what those scriptures
say.
So that will give Muhammad certainty of
that the Quran, oh yeah, it's true.
He'll know it's true once he sees that
it's in line with the Bible. If it's not
in line with the Bible, then that means
that the Quran is false, and Muhammad's
doubts would be confirmed, and he'll
have good reasons to reject the Quran.
Okay. Yeah. All right. So when Allah
when he says go to the scriptures before
you, right? I just want to know in your
context, what does that mean? Cuz it it
means something different for for us as
Muslims, what does that mean for you?
Well, it means to go check with the
previous scriptures, the Torah, Gospels,
Psalms, writings of the prophets
to verify whether or not the Quran is
telling the truth regarding these
things. Okay. Okay. So what are some
things
What are some things that um
that the Quran confirms? Not the Bible,
just like the Quran. What are some
things that the Quran confirms? It says
it confirms the scriptures as a whole.
No, what I mean is like what are some
things like for example, the Quran
confirms that there's only one deity of
worship. What do you What do you
worship? What are some claims that the
Quran makes? Yes. Okay. It's said it so
it it makes claims about the stories of
the prophets, their histories, and what
happened to them, what they went
through.
The children of Israel.
Okay. It mentions how Muhammad is
mentioned in these previous scriptures.
Mhm. So those are some things, those are
some claims that it makes.
Okay. So does the Quran confirm that
Jesus was a um an apostle of God? Yeah.
Does the Bible also confirm that Jesus
was an apostle of God? Yeah. Does the
Quran also confirm that Jesus was a
servant of God? Yeah. Does it also
confirm that Abraham, uh peace be upon
him, was he also a servant of God too as
well? Yeah.
Does the Bible confirm both of those
things that I just said?
Yes. Also to go along with um
does um the Quran and Bible both say
that um Adam is the first of all God's
creation? The first of his creation? The
first human is what I said at all. Okay.
>> Yes. Yeah. Okay. So we can see here that
um the Quran and the Bible they confirm
a lot of very very similar things to
each other.
Correct? Sure. But also the thing is
about it, you know that we believe that
the Bible has been corrupted and
changed. Wait, what What is that? Um I'm
confused.
Um I'm going to get to the argument, but
I'm saying you do know that.
That you believe that? Yes. Sure. Okay.
How does that help the point here that
I'm making? I don't understand.
>> What that the point
What the point is I'm trying to show you
here is that even though that the Quran
is is the final revelation of God that
was sent to it, but it's also it's
final, but then the Bible it confirms
every single thing that the Quran No, it
doesn't.
has claimed. So what's what's something
that that the Bible doesn't claim that
the Quran hasn't claimed? Just give give
me
two things. Two things? The Quran says
Jesus The Quran says Jesus wasn't
crucified, right? Mhm. The Bible says he
was crucified, right? I'm saying no, I
just Did you I just Did you know what I
just said? I said that even though that
the Bible is corrupted, everything that
is in the Quran everything that's in the
Quran
the Bible confirms it. The Bible
confirms it. It doesn't.
I'm talking about Now I'm talking about
every I'm talking about everything that
is in the Quran, everything. The Quran
says that Jesus wasn't crucified, right?
Mhm. Does the Bible confirm that? The
Bible does say that Jesus was crucified.
So it doesn't confirm what the Quran
said, right?
>> I would I mean like about like Jesus I
mean like about Jesus being a prophet of
God is what I meant.
The Quran says that the Quran says that
Jesus is not the son of God, right? No,
yeah, the Quran didn't say that. Does
the Bible say that?
>> I have to me
you have made you have made a good
point, but what I am trying to show you
But what I am trying to show you
>> Wait, wait, just really quick.
>> Cuz I said I said that wrong. Go ahead.
Go ahead. Go ahead. All right. So I I
appreciate your honesty.
So we can agree that there's some things
that the Quran and Bible agree on,
Mhm. and there's a lot of other things
that the Quran and Bible disagree on,
right? So that means that according to
1094, since if Muhammad is supposed to
if he's uncertain about the truth of the
Quran, and anybody, if you're uncertain
about the truth of the Quran, what
you're supposed to do is you're supposed
to go check the previous scriptures to
make sure the Quran is right. So if the
Quran disagrees with the previous
scriptures, then the Quran is false, and
you know that the Quran is not true.
But yes, but with the crucifixion thing,
of course yeah, Muhammad can go to the
Bible and see that Jesus was crucified.
But then again, is is it not debated Do
historians not debate Do some historians
believe that Jesus was crucified, right?
>> All All historians believe he was
crucified. All historians believe that
Jesus was crucified. Yes.
Every single historian. Yep, every
credible one. Okay. But yeah, so
does every I mean like every I'm sure
there's some historians that do not
believe that Jesus was crucified.
>> I'm I'm sure you can find some fake
historian who has who gets laughed out
of academia who will try to argue that
Jesus is a myth, Okay. but they they
they are not credible. Okay. But yes,
cuz Allah has already told Muhammad and
he said yes, Jesus was not crucified,
and you know, he was raised up.
Right.
>> Now what I'm saying So Muhammad will
know that the Quran got that wrong since
it contradicts the Bible, right? But
what I'm saying is we don't really know
if Jesus was crucified or not cuz like I
told you, there is somebody cuz I told
you we believe that somebody could have
took Jesus' place. Somebody took Jesus'
place. Yeah, that's not the point.
>> On the cross.
>> That's the
That's impossible. That's your belief
though. How How is that impossible? How
is that impossible? That's not the
argument. Whether you believe that or
not is fine. The point is is that the
Bible says Jesus was crucified, not that
he was switched out or it looked like he
It says Jesus was crucified and rose
again 3 days later from the dead. The
Quran says no, he wasn't crucified. Mhm.
Right? So regardless of what you believe
about that, the Quran is in direct
contradiction to the previous scripture,
which means that the Quran is false. It
got this wrong. So does the Quran also
make the claim that
that the scriptures have been changed
Does the Quran also make that claim or
no? It doesn't, but the Here's and
here's the important point. The
important point, Khalil,
is that 1094
makes the previous scriptures the
standard of truth. It makes it the
authority.
So whatever goes against the previous
scriptures is false.
Whatever is in line with the previous
scriptures is true.
So when the Quran is not in line with
the previous scriptures, that means the
Quran is false.
But it it is in line like still It's not
If the Quran and the Bible don't agree
on Jesus' crucifixion because there are
still Christians who believe in the
Bible that do not believe in Jesus'
crucifixion. So There's not There's not
a single Christian I'm not worried about
that. That That's like saying that
there's a Muslim that disagrees with
Muhammad being a prophet. Wait, are you
are you Wait, are you Are Unitarians not
Christians? Are Unitarians not
Christians No. No. No, they're not. But
even Unitarians believe Jesus was
crucified, dude. Unitarians believe that
Jesus was crucified as a sacrifice to
God. He died for us. Yes.
Are you sure? Come on, man. So do you
understand the point? The Quran
contradicts the Bible, so I I understand
I understand your point, but I feel like
I understand your point, but
I feel like we were talking about the
crucifixion too much. But I'm be saying
besides that Do you understand my point?
My point is that the Quran contradicts
the previous scripture, which means the
Quran is false because it goes against
the previous scripture. And where where
do you infer that? Where do you How do
you infer that? Chap Chapter 10 verse
94. No, but that's not that's not that's
not what it says. That's not what it
infers. It doesn't say that okay, yeah,
if the Quran is not in line with the
Bible, does it in fact say that means
that the Quran is false? Cuz that the
Quran and the Bible cuz there are some
things that the Quran and the Bible say
that is different. Because like I just
told you a few minutes ago that Slow
down. Slow slow down. Let's Let's Let's
Let's work through this one last time.
If you don't get it, then I'll move on.
Okay. The verse says, are you listening
to the verse? I'm about to read it out.
You ready? If you are in doubt about
that which we have revealed to you, then
go and ask those who have been reading
the scripture before you.
Mhm.
So going and asking those who read the
scripture before him should is going to
clear up his doubts about the Quran,
right?
Mhm.
Meaning that he's going to see that the
Quran is in line with the scriptures
that came before him, right?
>> Mhm.
And once he sees that the Quran is in
line with the scriptures that came
before, he'll know the Quran is true,
right? Okay. Okay. Yeah. Now that means
the opposite is true.
If he goes and checks the previous
scriptures
and he sees that the Quran actually
contradicts them and is not in line with
the previous scripture, then he'll know
the Quran is false, right?
So that means that if the Quran
contradicts the previous scripture,
then the Quran is false. If it's in line
with the previous scripture, the Quran
is true and Muhammad would know it's
true. That's what 1094 communicates.
Okay.
So okay, you finished now? Yes, did you
understand the point?
>> Yeah, I understand your point but before
I get started one last thing to ask you.
So
the verse does say right that the
Muhammad
if you go ask the people I mean the
scriptures the people who read the
scriptures and follow the scriptures
before you right and you go ask them you
say hey does that does your scripture
does it does it say this your scripture
doesn't say that or whatever. Like I
asked you earlier do the Quran and the
Bible both confirm those things yes or
no? Did I ask you before? Besides the
crucifixion I'm talking about the fact
that Jesus in a sense being a servant of
God somebody who submitted to the will
of God and somebody who worshipped a God
and had a God and somebody that was
humble right and somebody who confirmed
that there was only one true God same
thing with Ibrahim in the Bible Musa
whatever in the Bible okay? Does the
sure. Does the Quran contradict the
previous scriptures on other things
about Jesus and the prophets? It depends
what you mean by contradict.
>> Get off my stage. Get off the stage. You
don't belong here. Get off the stage.
Islam decay how you doing? You got logic
how are you? Good. Thank you. You're
welcome. So I can give you a short brief
of myself so you don't lose your spend
your time
for circles. Is that okay?
Are you a Muslim? Yes, I'm a Muslim.
Okay. You believe the Quran? Yes. I
I have a look at the Islamic dilemma and
I have have look all the refuse from
other Muslims. So it it doesn't it's not
a how can you it's not a topic that
affects me. So Okay. So you So I can I
can I'm not here to
convince you or something but I can
tell you about my status or situation.
I'm Muslim because I am convinced
that Islam is true and
and
the
previous scriptures is not a standard
for me. The standard is that Quran is a
miracle and that's why if Quran is was
not a miracle I wouldn't believe either
Islam or other religions. Do you believe
that the Quran tells you that it's the
standard of truth?
>> If the Quran
tells me if the standard is the true If
it's a standard of truth.
>> No my my my my my reason
my reason is the standard of true. Okay.
The Quran The Quran says that it is
reliant it is dependent upon the
previous scriptures to be true. It has
to be in line with the Bible or else the
Quran is false.
>> as as I said to you I have heard those
arguments
also from your videos
and from David Wood and so on and I also
have looked at the compared it with the
Muslims refutes as Daniel and the
Orthodox Muslim and so on. So I think
it's just a poor argument. So there is
no reason to discuss that. Well you just
saying that it's a poor argument doesn't
mean that it's it's a poor argument. I
think it's even with Okay let's let's
let's let's just say
yeah let's just say if I granted you
that your argument is
good to disprove Islam. So as I as I
said to you if Islam is not true there
is no religion for me. Okay. So I don't
want you to grant for the sake of
argument. I want you to see for yourself
that Islam is true and then you can
become an atheist after and then I can
probably give you the gospel then we'll
see. But according to the Quran
>> I don't know what what why should I why
should I be Christian if if I'm not
Muslim?
>> Well we'll we'll talk about
>> cannot see a proof from Christianity. I
cannot see a proof.
That that'll be phase two. But phase one
is breaking down the wall of Islam
first.
Okay so so you prefer that I'm an
atheist than a monotheist. You didn't
hear me. So according to your Quran its
truthfulness is based on it being in
line with the scriptures. Do you agree
or disagree with that?
>> Not exactly.
It
is just because you know the Antichrist
when he comes he makes
miracles.
And
if Prophet Muhammad came out of nowhere
and made a miracle as the Quran I will
not believe him if if if he was not a
continuous
because it doesn't make sense that God
creates the world and
and in centuries he doesn't reveal
himself and boom out of nowhere in the
7th century he reveals himself. So
that's why it must be a lineage. Do you
do you read the Quran? Yes, I read the
Quran. I also understand basic Arabic.
If the if the Quran got something wrong
is it from God? Is it a miracle from
God? That just mean that we got
something wrong in our
>> No the Quran I didn't say Yes, I'm
saying the Quran. If the Quran actually
factually got something incorrect if it
got it wrong would it be a miracle from
God still? No no of course not. Okay. So
the Quran gives us certain tests certain
things on how we can verify whether or
not the Quran
is from God or not okay? One of those
things is is that if there are
contradictions in it then it's not from
God. Two yes exactly.
>> If somebody can bring something like it
whether it be a verse or a chapter then
it's not from
>> sura. then it's not from Allah.
And three is that it is in line with the
previous scriptures. Muhammad is
mentioned in there. It's
it's in line when it comes to the
history of the prophets and what it
talks about the prophets and their
stories and what they believed and what
they taught it's in line with the
previous scriptures. If it's not in line
with the previous scriptures then the
Quran is not is false and not from God.
It doesn't have to be a perfect match
with the previous scriptures.
>> to be a perfect match because Allah
can't contradict his own word. Would you
agree?
>> Allah doesn't say that it is a very
reasonable when you look at previous
scriptures without the Quran even rabbis
and priests they say you don't take it
verbatim
because it's the word of the prophets
it's not the word of God it's the word
of prophets and for example I can give
you an example from
>> Is that what your Quran says? Does the
Quran say that the previous scriptures
are the words of prophets or does it say
it's his word?
>> Okay give give give me the words we can
look at it together. I'm in front of my
computer I can open quran.com. Chapter 3
verse 3. Just a moment bear with me.
Chapter 3 Verse 3. Verse 3. Okay. Okay
so can I read it in Arabic first? It
says
in fact we gave you the book
with truth confirming
what they have in front of them. And we
revealed
the Torah the Torah and in jail and the
good news the gospel. So is the Torah
and gospel the words of the prophets or
is it the word of Allah? God revealed
God revealed the Torah and in jail but
it never says it's the verbatim words of
God not here. It just say it reveals it
revealed the meaning. So we can
understand as it reveals the meaning
yes. Is the Quran the verbatim word of
Allah? Yes, that is. Can you show me
where the Quran says that?
>> Okay. Give me a moment. Okay. I don't
know the Quran in my memory like this so
I just find it.
It's okay. Okay you can look up
chapter 9 6 sura 9 and verse 6 and 2 3
4 5 6. So it says what in a had done
Quran
>> If any of the idolaters seek the seek
you protection grant them protection
till he hears the words of of Allah then
do you convey him to his place of
security that because they are people
who do not know. Where does it say that
the Quran is the words of Allah? It's
checking about the Quran. It doesn't say
that. Okay let me just want to do it
verbatim correct? That's right. I'm only
asking for this because you
that was your standard for the verse
that I showed you.
>> Yes yes yes yes yes. Okay. Okay it's the
same both of them both in jail and Torah
and Quran it is revealed by God. So
Okay. So would you say that the Torah
and gospel are the words of Allah too
the the same way that Quran is? The
original ones yes and Quran is making a
general confirmation not a specific
match exact match. The Quran never says
that so Because you have the words that
says Muhaymin. This this was my point
that the Quran that Allah cannot
contradict his words. Right? He can't so
when he's confirming something when he's
confirming his own words
he can't go against his own words. He
can't contradict his own words. We
agree? But he's not making a
exact confirmation he's making a general
confirmation and you have the words that
says Do you agree with that? The Quran
is Muhaymin. Do you agree with that
brother that Allah cannot contradict his
own words and go against his own words?
It cannot be a contradiction yes. It can
be abrogation but not contradiction.
Good. So when Allah is confirming the
previous scriptures he cannot be
contradicting them at the same time
right? Because those are his own words.
They have to be perfectly in line right?
If he had confirmed them exactly
verbatim word by word yes but he's not
never do that.
He never do that. He just makes a
general confirmation. Okay. So when you
say a general confirmation, are you
saying that Allah can confirm some of
his own words, but then contradict other
other parts of his words? No, I'm just
saying
he's
he's confirming
generally what the Jews had in the time
of the prophet. Does he contradict them?
Does he contradict his own words of the
past? He He contradicts what they have
in their hands by making conscious edits
to them. I'm really trying to work with
you. I can give you an example if you
want.
>> You're not answering what I'm asking.
You keep coming up with this fake
conscious edit story that you got from
the online Dawah boys. That's why I said
to you there's no need to go in this
cycle I started with this.
>> just one second. I'll I like to go cuz
you said you believe in the Quran, which
I'm seeing that you don't. None of you
guys do. I like to go with what the
Quran says.
>> I just said to you that I believe in the
Quran only because it's a miracle. Yeah,
I know. You don't believe in the words
>> my parents or my society. Yeah, no no
You don't believe in the words of it
all. You just believe just to believe.
My question was this. When you say that
he's making a general confirmation, and
answer this question, please, if you
can. If you can't, let's just move on.
I'll just move on to the next guest.
Okay. When is Allah confirming, like is
he in line with some of his words, but
then contradicting other parts of his
words? He will never do that. So, he has
to be perfectly in line with what he
said in the past, right? Exactly.
And if the scriptures was preserved
perfectly, that will be the case, but
the
preserved Thank you. Now, this is what I
want you to do for me now.
Can you show me where in the Quran it
says that the Quran only confirms
generally the scriptures? When Quran
says it's a Muhaiman,
I can give you the verse if you want.
I don't need that. That's chapter 5
verse 48. I know what verse 5 of chapter
5 verse 48 says. What I What I What I
need IslamDK
is not chapter 5 verse 48. What I need
is where the Quran says that it only
confirms generally the previous
scripture. Not that it's a guardian of
the
>> what That is what chapter 5:48 says.
Because when it's a guardian, it is
explicitly also
conscious added to the So, so brother
brother brother, I'm going to give you a
chance to be honest with me. I'm going
to give you a chance to be very honest
with me. Does chapter 5 verse 48 say
that the Quran is a general confirmation
of the previous scripture? Does it say
that in that verse? Be honest. I'm
giving you a chance.
>> It does It doesn't use that words, but
it means that. Got you. It implies it.
Okay.
So, you believe that the Quran is a
judge or corrector of the previous
scriptures, is that right? Exactly.
Okay.
In 10:94,
what does Allah tell you to do if you
doubt what the Quran is saying? Let me
look. 10:90 What did you say? Surah
Yunus.
>> Surah
Chapter 10. Surah Yunus. Just a moment.
Chapter of 10
94. What verse? 94. Okay.
Long the way. 94 95 94. Okay. It says
"Fain kunta" It doesn't speak to me. Who
does it speak to? It says if It's It
speaks to one person. Who's that?
>> Fain kunta. If you And that must be the
prophet. Okay. I'll go with that. So,
what does it tell Muhammad to do? Yes.
It says "Fishakkin If you are in doubt
mimman ilayka" What What we have
revealed to you. "Fasalina
yaqra'unal
kitaba" Yes. So, so I have the words.
You can come with your point. So,
Muhammad, if he's doubting what the
Quran says, is supposed to go check with
the previous scriptures, right? Okay. It
says "If you, oh prophet, are in doubts
about these stories"
That's a parenthesis. Okay.
"That we have revealed you, then ask
those
who read the scripture." It doesn't say
go to the scripture. It says go to who
reads the scripture. And where would
And where would they be getting their
information from to answer Muhammad's
doubts? I don't know. But
But the Quran says ask ask ask the Jews.
But if you go with the words
>> stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop. Okay.
Ask the people who Ask the people who
what?
>> Who reads the scripture. So, where are
they getting their information from? I
don't know. Some scripture they had in
that time. There you go. And what
scripture did they have? I don't know.
The Torah and the Gospel, right? Yes,
the Torah and Gospel, but which version,
I don't know.
>> So, no worries. So, the Quran says for
Muhammad to go check essentially with
the previous scriptures.
The people who read the previous
scriptures, who's who are going to be
using the previous scripture to answer
him. Yes, but Whether or not
to to clear up his doubts that he might
have about the Quran, right? Yes, but
But let let me just make this issue I
have with this verse. It is not talking
to me. It's It's a word for the
prophet.
>> to Muhammad. Muhammad, the best example
for all mankind, right? Yes. Okay. So,
the best example for all mankind, the
one whose footsteps you're supposed to
follow, the Quran tells you Yes.
that if he's in doubt about what the
Quran says,
what is he supposed to do to go check
the Quran? Go and ask some humans that
are living in his time. Who do what? Who
read the scriptures, right? Who read the
scripture.
So, basically
>> going to the Muhammad has to go
and get information from the previous
scripture to make sure that the Quran is
in line with those
and and he'll know the Quran is true,
right? Not previous scriptures because
he cannot read and write. He just go to
Which is why he has to ask the people.
He can't read them themselves, that's
why he has to ask.
>> Yes.
They're going to read it for him, right?
>> Exactly. So, therefore, the
So, the Quran has to match the previous
scriptures, and when Muhammad hears what
the what the previous scripture says
from these people,
he'll know the Quran is true because
it's lined up with what they have,
right? It doesn't has to match. He just
go has to go and ask them. For example,
when he asked
people of the scripture, they are
telling You don't belong here. I let you
on long enough. I should have cut you a
long time ago. I should have stopped the
question the conversation when you said
you only believe in the Quran as a
miracle. That's where I should have
stopped it. But I I I let you I let you
I tried to reach you.